hello everyone and welcome to game 54 of
the 100 game match between lee laches
zero and stockfish in the TCC super
finals we've already seen two of the
game sub early from this super finals
last one was game 49 this is game 54 and
it's a really really an impressive game
I'm sure you're all gonna enjoy it
before I show you the game I would just
like to say that I have received my copy
of the game changer by Mathew settler
and Natasha Regan it's a book about
alpha zero is groundbreaking chess
strategies and the promise of and the
promise of AI with a foreword by Garry
Kasparov and the introduction by D point
CEO demis hassabis I still haven't read
it so I'm very much looking forward to
it and just so you know this is not a
paid promotion or something like that I
only promote things I enjoy myself on
this channel so that means said let's
check out this very nice game now Oliva
has the white pieces and like we already
mention in this 100 game match the d
openings are pre-arranged so we're gonna
discuss that as the game goes in this
game we had d4 d5 c4 and c6 the Slav
defense Knight to f3 Knight to f6
we have III and Bishop f5 one of the
nicer ways that I decide what to do with
your light square Bishop is death
usually blacks the biggest problem we
have Knight to c3 and now comes c6 so
now you have this very nice triangle
here the bishop is out of the box and
white will of course do everything it
can to to harass it so immediately we
have nice to h4 going for the bishop and
now Bishop to g4 attacking whites Queen
we have Queen to b3 and now as the b7
point is under attack the bishop is no
longer guarding at Queen to c7 defending
the point with h3 now forcing the bishop
back we have Bishop to h5 and now this
is how it works in this 100 game match
first Lila has the white pieces they
play this opening then stock which has
the white pieces they play this exact
same opening and leah has to defend it
with the black pieces and here stockfish
in this position played Bishop to d2 and
it's a no more humans have played this
move in this position also but Lila goes
for g4 and I always find it amazing how
both leah and alpha I always find a way
to just
coupons just a 8:4 h5g 4g5 just make
everything open and you know just leave
your king in the center like like it
doesn't matter but okay Bishop to g6 it
was played in human chess plenty of
times g5 now attacking the knight and
first an in-between move and I situation
took the captaincy for attacking whites
Queen
we have Bishop captures grabbing the
pawn while developing a piece nice the
d5 getting to the knight out of the way
and now Knight captures in g 6h captures
and g6 and now efore again with an
attack on the knight Knight captures on
c3b captures on c3 and there were three
games in the database I found that
reached this exact same position and in
in in all three games rook to h4 was the
move going after this efore pot and it's
a very rich position in one of the games
white one in 100 games black one and one
game was a draw
but here a stock field goes for a
different move Knight to d7 and now it's
only moves for 14 but we already have a
completely new game so let's see how
Leela goes about this first Bishop to e2
a very nice move and a very useful move
but you'll see later just what what it
does for one it doesn't allow b5 to come
with an attack on the bishop so black
and white can always react with a four
to b5 and on the other on the other hand
it also keeps on this rook to h4 move
which we already mentioned human played
humans played as now for example up to
84 you can just unlock that rook in with
Bishop to g4 so Bishop to d6 a very nice
developing square for the Bishop but
also it kind of invites Leah to go for a
5 as now white is really controlling a
lot of very important central squares so
Leela does go a5 and okay Bishop back to
e7 putting pressure on the g5 point and
now King to f1 now Leela although
decided not to castle will go kingi - to
defend the h2 report and then the Rope
will be free - to enter the game
b5 and now comes a four it's a very
principled move where black has played
be five to go a4 you wanna trade your or
less even less central
for his less central pawn but here it's
a it loses upon but it's it's amazing
how how beautiful this pawn sacrifice is
but but you'll see what I mean
Lila goes for a four we have Queen to a5
now now you cannot capture because the
rook on a1 is undefended with King to g2
Oliva just you know doesn't care what
what's going on here and nice the b6
stockfish now is ready to capture this
pawn and there's not not much you can do
to defend it
we have Queen to c2 a beautiful move
that you'll see very soon just just how
powerful it is Stokely decides it's okay
to capture the pawn we have Knight
captures on a4 and now comes Bishop to
f3 so what's Leela's compensation for
the pawn here for a moment
the threat is Bishop captures and c6
delivering a check and winning the
rockin a8 so Queen back to c7 in
defending and now comes H for preparing
the h5 as you see the Queen is attacking
the g6 pawn and this will be one of the
reasons why most of blacks ideas don't
work for example you might think okay I
want to push c5 I can't my rookies on a8
I could play something like this and
then push c5 but it doesn't work because
the queen is on c2 for example but
should be too and now black pushes c5
White has d5 and after E captures now II
6 and now you see that black blacks
position slowly but surely crumbles for
example if you capture then you get
Queen captures and g6 and it's all over
King comes here rook it comes to e1 and
you're just gonna pile up on this point
you're winning the g7 pawn then you're
pushing h5 h6 this is completely over so
after h4 we have Queen to d7 and now
comes h5 again going for this g6 pawn
the idea of Queen being and c2 another
nice thing about the Queen and c2 when
white pushes c4 black will not be able
to recapture as the Queen also pressures
the night even after the rook moves from
a 1 G captures on h5 you can't really
allow white to capture here so we have G
captures on h5 and now not recapturing
you could do that but even better g6
just make things happen in media
again f captures is not possible due to
Queen captures and now you will either
have to run away and then after Queen
captures on g7 you're also losing this
bone and everything just crumbles bishop
is coming to G for you are capturing the
e6 pawn or if you go to f8 then just
Bishop captures and there's a very
little you can do about this Queen f7
checkmate
you could play Bishop b8 okay Queen
guard Queen guards at but now locate
three the rook is coming to f3 Queen c7
now comes look f3 check King moves and
now a black is either getting checkmate
it or loses the Queen so a very
difficult position for black we have f6
keeping black alive but allowing white
to have this beautiful pawn on g6 we
have 8 captors on f6 and now Bishop
captures G captures seems to give you
more control here but the g7 is just too
powerful look here you get Bishop
captures with check King d8 but now
Queen here attacking the rook and after
you can have two rooks then finally
Bishop f7 will either wind rook or you
will move it and white will promote into
a queen and then black pol eventually
have to give up the exchange so after it
captures on f6 with Bishop captures and
finally now rook comes to 81 preparing
to put pressure on d6 pawn for example
Queen b3 and then capturing here and
it's interesting can can black do
something like castles and then just
bring the rook over here and try to
defend everything yeah you can but then
you have this pawn on h5 you can always
just go Bishop e3 attack the rook after
look moves Bishop captures and it's a
very easy to imagine this Queen creeping
up all the way here the bishop
controlling the dark squares it will be
it will be very unpleasant for the black
king so after rook e1 we have looked to
f8 and now Queen b3 going after this
point like we said Bishop to e7
now comes c4 again we mentioned you
cannot capture because the knight would
be lost so much for that night on a4
rook the c8 and now comes C captures on
b5 seek after Sun b5 and now what do you
do with the six pawn feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out what to
do about this position I'll give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who decided look
Church on e6 that's that's not gonna fly
because although it seems like yeah
white is controlling much more space the
ponies here controlling f7 you want to
play something like rook captures play
Bishop e3 go other look on me one just
double rooks it doesn't work because of
if you capture Black has this very nice
tactic of rook captures on f3 now you
cannot capture with the Queen because
you have to keep an eye on your rook and
of course if King captures then you have
this very unfortunate rip the c3 check
would be very happy as he would win the
Queen here and finally there would be
some use of this knight on e4 other than
grabbing that pawn
so after C capture some b5 we have Queen
captures on e6 this is the strongest
Queen captures now rook captures and now
we have rope to f6 and this move Leila's
next move reminded me of The Fight Club
that's why I named the video like this I
believe it's Tyler Durden or is there
then who who mentions at one point be
careful of the things you own or or they
might end up owning you so here it seems
that you can either capture here or you
can move the rook and give away your g6
pawn and this g6 bone is basically the
thing that will end up owning you if you
don't just you know leave it be for
example if you capture them okay the
pawn stays alive but after Bishop
captures the this pawn is pressured you
have to defend it now comes rook c4 and
it seems like black untangled it's it's
actually black who's pushing now so here
lil I find that I found a different idea
rook 285 giving up the g6 pawn with
check and okay rook captures and now
King to f1 and now you see that white
has so many threats Bishop captures on
h5 one of them winning the rook on g6 so
you have to do something about this King
to f8 but now rook captures on h5
threatening rook h8 check and winning
the rook and c8 king f7 defending and
now not going for material right away
first and push up to d5 check and now if
you go something like into f8 then of
course a rope to H it will be checkmate
you don't want to all-out this if you
try something like King to f6 not really
possible because it loses the rook
Bishop b4 wins the rope here
rogue g4 you get rook f5 check King e6
and now you get rook
five check King back and now f3 will win
the rook rook ji-sook g3 you can just
attack it here and even if a Bishop d6
just captures and you will you will be
down a piece by the end of all of the
exchanges so after Bishop b5 check King
t8 was played and now first Bishop to b2
you do want to get your last piece the
rook and Bishop into the game as well a
six now defending the b5 point and now
rook to e1 now white will make it very
nice use of this pin and here we have
King to d7 you don't want roll out this
pin to exist rookie v just doubles rugs
Bishop is coming to before it would be
too too dangerous so push up the e4 here
attacking the rook now Lilla will start
a rock hunt with the bishop pair when it
when it's an open board and you have a
bishop pair of white has a black has
loose rooks you mostly you can do
something about this rook to f6 and now
comes roof to d5 check and this is the
critical moment of the game but not in
that's not a critical moment of the game
where black can actually do something
it's a critical moment of the game where
black is just dead because of whatever
black does not with the King let's say
he goes King c6 you get rook c1 check
King has to go to b7 to defend the rook
here looked a d7 check King b8 now you
get rook the b7 check and here you're
just getting checkmated on the other
hand after this rook to d5 check you
could decide to go something like king
c7 but still Bishop f5 attacks the rook
and also the bishop that's undefended
here and pretty much whatever you do you
can defend the bishop but then comes
rook d7 check after you move the King
then comes the Bishop g4 the threat is
just winning the piece here and after
it's defended it now comes d5 check King
c5 and not Roxy 1 check King will have
to move and now d6 just either wins the
bishop or the rook on f7 so not possible
either so not working not working what
else can you do if you go King e6 you
get Bishop g2
I discovered to check while keeping an
eye on your rook King f7 and now rook d7
again the threat is winning the bishop
rukia defending and now Bishop to b4 one
of the reasons why Bishop to d2 was
placed to allow this attack and if rocky
says then just Bishop d5
is just beautiful here I mean not not
anything you can do
so after rugby 5 we said doesn't work
doesn't work doesn't work and lastly we
have King he ate but again rocky 5 just
doubling up here and the e-file black
will not be able to repeal this King f8
you get Bishop to g5 now attacks the
rook rope to f7 and now Bishop to f5
again we have a triple attack here and
the rook here is under attack
after rocky eight or something you just
get bishop g6 and it's all over
black black has too much to deal with
you can either just give up material or
try a very nice checkmate like this so
any of the lines for the King are not
possible so stockfish decided for Bishop
to d6 but this just allows Lilith to win
the exchange straight up Bishop f5 check
when the exchange rope captures rook
captures and now Knight beat you so here
Leela is down upon but up the exchange
and okay black does have to connect to
pass pawns on the Queen side but you
know a rook is a rook King e2 we have
King to e6 and now comes Ruby g5 going
after the pawn and here black will have
to go into somewhat of a passive
position to keep an eye on the g7 point
Bishop to f8 and now comes look at v
check King g8 and now Bishop to e3
now the next idea for white ista is to
grab some of the points on the Queen
side before stockfish starts pushing the
past pawn rook c1 now the bishop is
defending the rook so Leela would like
to exchange rooks rugby 8 I'm not
allowing this bishop player for
attacking the rook rook e8 check King to
d2 and now comes a rook to d8 attacking
the pawn Bishop to e3 and now Bishop to
e7 so stockfish is very comfortable here
he would like to keep it a draw but we
have looked the c6 now attacking the a6
pawn and there's not much you can do to
defend it you could try something like
rook to 8 but then you're just in a
passive position and starts pushing the
past pawn bishop to f6 was played enough
stalkerish tries to give up the ace
exponent for the d4 pawn but simply king
c2 attacking the knight here 9 a4 and
only now ro captures on a6 would an
attack on the night and
here we have Knight to c3 so here we
have a position where the both Li lines
doctors have two points but little is up
the exchange and this is only moved 53
so this is one of the things when we
first saw I believe it was the first
game between alpha 0 and stockfish we're
also alpha had a winning end game but
stockfish tortured him for like a
hundred more moves and that's that's how
you should approach chess when you have
a position like this just torture your
opponent just make him think make him
make him you know work for his meal and
that's what stockfish does but okay
queen d3 a king this really was mine
King to f7 and now comes Luke f2e rook
after a five King to g6 and now we have
rook to be six going after the b4 pawn
and this is the next step of the plan
night
we have Knight to d5 and now comes Luke
beat to b5 first and Knight to e7 here
stockfish wants to trickle you in the
capturing so as to win at least two who
won rook allele is not interested rook
to e8 one we have rook to d6 now and
rook captures on before finally now
Eli's up the exchange and the pawn and
now it's only a matter of time when I
see six attacks the rook rock a4 with
King here
rugby one in 95 check King goes back
Knight to 7 and rook to d1 look to be
six and now rook to d2 knife along again
each X King g6 and now King to f3 Knight
g5 check the captures Bishop captures
and now rugby one allele I was able to
exchange one more piece and now with
with such a huge advantage it's merely a
matter of improving your Kings position
and pushing the pawn rook f6 check King
g2 Bishop f4
rogue d3 King the five and now rugby
three
King to d6 king of three verse of g5
room d3 bishop prevents rook a5 check
and now rook be for preparing room b5
check
we have rope here King goes back ruga d6
and now King to e3
rook to d5 rook to d1 Bishop to e7
attacking the rook rook a4 and worship
to f6 so for the moment a stopper still
torturing gorilla we have looked the sea
for preparing rook to c5 to exchange
so Bishop to e7 not allowing it look to
be one now trying to get the other look
up Bishop to f6 rugby to be four again
rope to c5 is a threat to exchange rooks
so King has to move King today for rook
moves and now rope to a four D file was
probably an option immediately but Lila
wants to prepare everything perfectly so
improving the position slowly by slowly
even f3 okay Bishop f6 we have looked to
be 7r oka for rugby one King Li for King
g6 rock a three we have Rock b8 na cons
rugby three rocky eight check King goes
to f4 King h5 and now King g3 rugby 8d v
now finally starts pushing the past pawn
and in here it's a merely merely a
matter of technique which Leo does not
lack so the king is coming up the board
and here looked rookie six attacks
Bishop rook checks King attacks Bishop
Bishop e7 roopd to e3 and here after
Bishop to g5 stockfish resigned the game
as now there's really nothing to do the
King is already very close you can just
move the rook put it behind a passed
pawn prepared to push it and after let's
say Roxy one check you can go King d7
Bishop to f4 preparing this rook here
but then you just go lucky seven check
King moves and now you can just push d6
block the bishops control of the c7
square and whatever black plays you will
just go rook e8 let's say g5 you will
check black King g7 you will even
capture here and now you'll just move
the King and when win the game with your
passport so one of the one of the
possibilities but yeah I mean the game
lasted for 111 moves and we said that
unmoved 53 I was already a completely
winning endgame for Leo
simply a matter of technique but
stockfish torture therefore for 50-plus
moves so that's how you should approach
chess you should always torture your
opponents and you know just give him
he'll make them work for their meal so a
wonderful game again 54 of the TCC super
final season 14 I'm very very excited
see where this goes will Lila be able to
win this match not she's currently two
points in the lead ahead of stockfish
which is which is really unreal because
up until last year we when alpha zero
was released we never even thought
thought it possible for for stockfish to
be defeated yes okay maybe in a game but
never in a match so this is
groundbreaking stuff and and a good time
to be alive you know for chess Sam
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Barnard more
Janish Cove ski barrows Johanna Hughes
and the NVRA Sony for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more interesting content checking
up on Leela and continuing the capo
blanca saga and of course follow the
match between Leela and starfish live
the first thing you will see in the
description below is a link to to their
match thank you all and I will see you
soon